Hãy gọi là thủ địch cho đến khi có thông bó mời,
ông Nhân Mạnh Thôi điểm chấm giữ xe sử xe sọng iroan quy định
và các nỗ lực nhằm hạn giả năng lượng chiếm mơ tính tạm thời trong điều kiện trên trang.
Tên bố được đưa ra trong bố tạng tạng thẳng thẳng tại Trung Đông đang đầy ra rầu thư.
Tên bố tạng mạnh lên trên một trang đu lòng Mỹ một thông,
mất cầu nhất kể từ khi xung đột ngà của quảy nả bủng phát năm 2020.
Chúc khi tạm giảm xuống quan tạm lòng đu lòng Mỹ một thông, sau khi tổng thống Mỹ đô đàn trang cho rằng
trên dưới quan sử gọi thế, sớm kết thúc.
Trong khi đó, anh cho biết đang phủ hợp với các đồng mình để xem sẽ cất biển pháp hỗ trợ tổ thông
mạc đi qua yêu biển hòa mốt trong đối cảnh tạng thẳng giả tạng.
Nghe phân ngôn của thủ tường anh Kills Tạm Mơ Chó biết,
lần đơn đã thảo lượng với lãnh đạo đất và ita liá về tâm quan trọng của việc bảo đam
tương gió hàng hải tại tuyến vất tại chiến lượng này.
Cung ngày phát thúng báo trình khai khoảng 1 trục tổ chến bao gồm nhóm tác chến
tổ sẵn bài cháu lì để gồm tới đưa chúng hại, bình đò và có thể cả
ở bên hôm út, nhằm bảo vệ tương gió hàng hải và hỗ trợ các đồng mình trong khu vực.